12 est à présent face à la première
[Musique]
si je vous annonce quelques noms comme
ceux de jeanne les rôles et c'est au nom
d'al suzanne aussi crg en thiérache imed
en tirant davis disait la limite vous
comprendrez aisément que je me réfère
aux mouvements féministes évidemment
cette sélection est subjective que
signifie précisément le terme de
féminisme que recouvre ce terme de nos
jours on la condition des femmes
justifie t'elle encore plus failli se
battre pour conquérir des droits
nouveaux ou consolider des droits acquis
ou supposés mental en ce dimanche 7 mars
à la veille du 8 mars journée
internationale de lutte pour les droits
des femmes
je vous propose d'évoquer ces questions
avec nos invités à ce nouveau numéro de
face à la première c'est l'émission
politique de la rédaction de martinique
la première réalisée par adel doux et
paul eric tous et nos invités
tout d'abord par ordre alphabétique une
militante aux rita bonnes herbes ont
jauni talonneur dont son président ta de
lui fm l'union des femmes de martinique
du fm qui a publié en 1900 2019
un ouvrage collectif intitulé jane léro
une pionnière du mouvement féministe
martinique
un ouvrage réalisé par cécile seulement
et llano ce temps catherine et marc
camille pancartes et marie-josèphe hardy
dessources et d'ail vous allez nous a
parlé tout à l'heure il y as avec nous
également mais à paris une sociologue
audrey célestine bonjour madame
célestine jour bonjour merci de nous ne
vous joindre à nous vous êtes maîtresse
de conférences de sociologie à
l'université de lille n'ont pas de l'île
de la martinique mais de lille que le
nom de la france elie 2 l1 et je vous
invite et parce que vous avez publié
récemment
le recueil de portraits de femmes noires
qui s'appelle david combat femme noire
en est libre aux éditions l'iconoclaste
livre très récent qui n'a même pas six
mois et on fait avec nos une historienne
fabienne janas bonjour madame jeanne à
son ancien professeur d'histoire et de
géographie au lycée de bellevue à fort
de france et vous êtes membre de
l'association aux lions la caraïbe qui
essaieront groupement de chercheuses et
chercheurs en sciences sociales dont le
but est de vulgariser de populariser la
discipline historique mais de manière
générale les disciplines des sciences
sociales avant d'échanger avec vous mais
dans un bref rappel de ce que signifie
ce 8 mars parce qu'il ya des fantômes de
confusion là encore il ya quelques
années on en entendait parler de journée
de la femme jour de la femme fête de la
femme bref avec audry goût venait nous
allons rappeler quelle est l'importance
de cette journée du 8 mars les femmes
socialistes sont les premiers à avoir
revendiqué cette date du 8 mars comme
étant la journée de la femme à
l'occasion de leur congrès à copenhague
au danemark en 1910 initiative née de la
journaliste allemande clara zetkin les
participants à ce congrès acte désormais
cette date ou en faire chaque année la
propagande en faveur du vote des femmes
une décision n'est de l'instauration le
28 février 1909 de la journée nationale
de la femme aux états unis à la pelle là
encore du parti socialiste d'amérique
après la première guerre mondiale c'est
le mouvement communiste qui s'empare
cette fois de la revendication avec en
pointe la révolutionnaire russe
rosa luxembourg la revendication
s'internationalise progressivement au
point que presque la totalité des états
membres des nations unies légalise le
droit pour les femmes de voter autre
date à retenir celle de 1977 année de
l'officialisation par l'onu de la
journée internationale des femmes
célébrée désormais presque sur toute la
planète
voilà pour ce rappel historique
présentée par audrey gauvin est l'une
des journalistes la rédaction de
martinez que la première
au vita bonheur c'est quand même
difficile de rappeler d'avoir rappelé
chaque année qui ne s'agit pas d'une
fête le moment par an que ting publicité
ou que sais-je encore juste parce
qu'autour de vous vous êtes ep agacé par
enfant par ce que vous entendez à la
radio à la télévision comme on voit ici
où les affiches que j'attendais
simplement d'alang au sujet de ce
immense c'est vrai c'est vrai que chaque
année à la proche de cette date bien il
faut rappeler que ce n'est pas la
journée de la femme ce n'est pas la fête
des femmes ce n'est pas l'occasion
d'offrir des roses même si les femmes
aiment les fleurs mais pas que mais
voilà mais pas que les femmes les hommes
aussi aime les fleurs donc effectivement
il faut sans cesse rappeler que c'est
une journée de revendications comme l'a
expliqué audrey govindin que c'est une
journée de lutte que c'est une journée
pour rappeler est bien ce que vivent les
femmes au quotidien les inégalités et
les discriminations les violences et que
eh bien cette journée bien entendu n'est
pas la seule journée où il faut
revendiquer mais c'est une façon au jour
vidéo comme toutes les journées
internationales c'est comme c'est une
façon de mettre en exergue de souligner
de pouvoir manquer particulièrement ces
événements c'est ses idées et cette
dynamique donc c'est pour cela que les
féministes l'investissent énormément
qu'est une question pour vous y rendre
et célestine qu'est-ce que ça provoque
en vous quand on ne comprend toujours
pas après quasiment un siècle
destot ration de cette journée qu'il
s'agit d'une journée un peu particulier
enfin et peut-être tout le toit total en
particulier a consacré à un rappel des
droits des femmes
ils ont ça provoque à la fois un
agacement mais enfin une envie de
pédagogie de rappeler encore et encore
que l'histoire c'est pas juste à un
espèce de long cheminement vers de plus
en plus de droits on a des périodes
d'avancé puis des périodes de recul
qu'on a des inégalités structurelles ce
que les gens ont du mal à comprendre et
à envisager
et puis à un véritable besoin d'affirmer
encore et encore les droits des femmes
les droits qu'elles ont à disposer de
leur corps
le droit
à obtenir une rémunération égale à celle
des hommes qui font le même travail etc
et ça c'est effectivement une sont des
revendications et des demandes qui ne
qui ne peuvent pas cessé parce que
malgré certains progrès les situations
restent difficiles et toujours menacée
dans la plus grande partie du monde
enfin ben jannet ce look est enseigné
l'histoire je pense que vous avez parlé
de cette journée avec vos élèves
femmes et hommes et que vous avez aussi
une vision de certains reculs la manière
dont elle considérait cette journée du 8
mars parmi les jeunes martiniquaise et
manon sinico alors dans le cadre de
l'éducation nationale on est sensibilisé
justement la transmission de ces valeurs
et de la prise en compte de la nécessité
de faire un bilan de ce 8 mars sur les
conquêtes mais aussi sur les remises en
cause qui sont quand possible quant au
droit que qui ont été acquis gagnés de
longue lutte et nous faisons une
sensibilisation une éducation non sexuée
nous sensibilisons nos élèves justement
à ces valeurs d'égalité entre filles et
garçons
en faisant cela nous respectons
simplement les directives de l'éducation
nationale puisqu'il ya une convention
dans en 2000 qui justement promouvait
une éducation égale qu'ils favorisaient
les questions d'égalité entre filles et
garçons et les hommes et les femmes dans
plusieurs domaines dans l'éducation
nationale c'est vrai mais aussi dans le
domaine du travail et c'est donc chaque
année on a des activités pour promouvoir
une éducation non sexiste mais que
l'impact de ces programmes de ses leçons
sur les jeunes sont ils sont elles la
sensibiliser sensible zend et à ses
valeurs d'égalité entre femmes et hommes
alors on a deux profils parmi nos élèves
tant chez les filles que chez les
garçons un premier groupe qui estime que
bon c'est bon tout a été fait non pas de
souci elles sont en elles sont à peu
près au même niveau que leurs camarades
du sexe masculin et l'autre profil
justement qui est sensible qui est déjà
sensibilisés
à ces différences à ces inégalités au
sein de leur famille soit parce qu'elles
ont subis des formes de discrimination
elle aussi soit parce qu'elles sont déjà
assez attentive à certains réseaux
sociaux ou des jeunes s'emparent de ces
questions surtout qu'il y à un mouvement
féministe aujourd'hui qui pose la
question au niveau des jeunes et aussi
au niveau des de tout ce qui est lgv t
la communauté homosexuelle etc qui parle
beaucoup aussi un logement 1,8 à bonheur
la lune à c'est la journée mondiale ou
internationale de lutte pour les droits
des femmes
comment en tant que militante féministe
percevez vous le fait que cette cause
n'est consacré ne célébrez qu'une seule
journée sur les 365 de l'année je pense
que c'est ce que je disais tout à
l'heure c'est à dire que bon il y a des
journées et atteint 10 pour tous 1
que ce soit pour baigner les petits
chiens que pour des revendications
beaucoup plus importante
donc pour moi c'est une façon de mettre
en exergue les droits des femmes
à un moment donné mais bien entendu il
ne s'agit pas uniquement dans cette
journée de de parler des droits des
femmes et de et de revendiquer c'est un
combat de tous les jours et on le sait
très bien bon quand on est confronté à
la réalité quotidienne de ce que vivent
les mâles les femmes et dans et dans
tous les pays il faut pas oublier que
bon ne soyons pas nombriliste ne
regardons pas la martinique où la france
où ou même l'europe les droits des
femmes sont très
différents d'un pays à l'autre et autant
bien dans certains pays le viol des
jeunes filles est considéré comme un
sport national n'est ce pas comme en
inde ou en afrique du sud
autant eh bien vous avez des avancées
dans d'autres pays bon qui rejaillissent
d'ailleurs surtout les sur tous les pays
et c'est cela qu'il faut garder en tête
dans la législation française est un
crime pour lequel on en compte jusqu'à
30 ans de prison
oui par exemple mais aussi quand on voit
que l'avortement et en europe
enfin en france en particulier depuis
depuis 75 et que et bien les argentines
ont célébré leur victoire en 2020
finalement de cette victoire sur la
vente pour l'avortement
donc on voit bien que les choses
avancent au gré aussi des mobilisations
au gré de la pression des féministes de
la pression populaire en général
puisqu'il n'y a pas que les femmes nous
disons toujours que les problèmes
comment dire que le féminisme c'est un
problème de société c'est pas un
problème qui intéresse que les femmes ça
concerne la société tout entière et et
faire avancer les droits des femmes
c'est faire avancer la société toute
entière
donc voilà c'est un combat de tous les
jours c'est un combat auquel on
s'attelle c'est un combat qui est qui
est constant parce que comme le disait
fabienne janas tout à l'heure eh bien il
ya des avancées il ya des reculs est
donc partout on avance ça fait avancer
les droits dans le monde entier partout
ont reculé bien c'est une remise en
question pour les femmes du monde entier
aussi
alors je me retourne vers ev célestine à
paris qui enseignait la sociologie à
lille mais en même temps vous êtes sion
la capitale française
et si on gronde capitale régionale
ouverte sur l'europe sur l'europe du
nord notamment lille
vous avez l'habitude de rencontrer des
jeunes vous étudiez vous étudiante
d'origine française même d'origine
française diversifiée mais également des
étrangers ou des étrangères cette
journée deux immenses a fait écho
évidemment autour de vous est ce que
qu'est ce que vous vous en avez perçu
qu'est-ce que vous apercevez depuis
quelques années comment les jeunes
étudiants et étudiantes que vous
fréquentez que vous encadrez comme
contribuer à former un perçoivent le
féminisme alors ce qui est intéressant
c'est que moi je alors malheureusement
mes étudiants et étudiantes je les vois
beaucoup sur l'écran ce moment c'est un
peu le problème mais ça règle de manière
générale mais étudiants et mais
exigeante âgées une grande majorité de
filles dans le département dans lequel
j'enseigne sont très sensibilisés à ces
questions ils sont très sensibilisés
d'une manière un peu particulière -
j'enseigne beaucoup la sociologie des
états unis l'histoire politique et
sociale des états unis et du coup c'est
vrai qu'on aborde de manière plus simple
que dans d'autres départements
académique en france les questions
autour de l'intersection alité sur la
manière dont les dominations vont
s'exercer de manière particulière et
renforcé sur les femmes noires sur des
femmes noires pauvres et sur voilà la
position particulière que peuvent avoir
certaines dans l'histoire des états unis
est en fait il ya vraiment de grands
phénomènes de d'identification da par
des étudiantes et des étudiants c'est à
dire qu'il ya une vraie compréhension de
du fait que les dominations s'exerce pas
sur tout le monde de la même manière et
une sensibilisation à ces enjeux de
manière générale y compris si déjà nous
sommes enfin moi je trouve que la
génération actuelle en tout cas voir là
dedans la population des étudiants de
ceux des sciences sociales qui ce qui
n'est pas forcément très représentative
il ya une compréhension des enjeux et de
la complexité de ces enjeux là et c'est
ce que je trouve plutôt rassurant dans
un contexte politique qui l'est un peu
moins parce qu'on est effectivement dans
une période de d'avancé dérober des
discours et des pratiques qui vont à
l'encontre des droits des femmes comme
je le disais janssen beaucoup sur les
états unis il ya certains états des
états unis dans lesquelles il est à peu
près impossible pour une femme d'avoir
accès à l'avortement ou les menaces
contre le planning familial sont
immenses ça c'est une réalité
d'aujourd'hui et ça je pense que voilà
les étudiants et des étudiantes sont
sont sensibilisés du coup au fait que
les acquis ne sont pas pour toujours et
qu'il faut se battre un peu au quotidien
pour pour les maintenir
alors justement fabien déjà dassin par
l'un de ses acquis est-ce que vous en
tant que grand saignante en tant que
jeune citoyenne martiniquaise vous avez
hérité d'une certaine culture et parmi
la culture de résistance de lutter il y
as depuis une soixante dix ans depuis
1944 la création de l'iufm de son terme
d'acquis pour les droits les droits des
femmes est-ce que vous avez perçu que
ses droits fondamentaux
on peut être remis en cause
bompard en moque de pression de
mobilisation populaire pourront trouver
les mots de ta bonheur de tout à l'heure
où au contraire on peut penser qu'une
fois que c'est acquis mais on ne peut
plus revenir en arrière
ben il y a un thème qui revenue dans la
bouche de chaque intervenant tu sais la
question notamment de l'avortement
je rappelle quand même que dans la
caraïbe oui en martinique et en
guadeloupe l'avortement illégalisé
depuis 75 mais plus près de chez nous en
haïti en république dominicaine ou dans
d'autres îles de la caraïbe comme la
jamaïque a fortement est interdit donc
tout près de chez nous dans certains
pays européens
ces acquis sont encore gruissan en
espagne ces acquis ont été remis en
cause
en france il y a encore des débats vous
avez parlé du viol tout à l'heure il
faut savoir que le viol a été défini
comme un crime en 1981 sous la pression
des communistes parti communiste et
féministe excusez moi donc aujourd'hui
encore il ya des remises en questions
sur la définition du viol
est-ce qu'on remet en cause la
responsable a une part de responsabilité
de la victime vous avez toutes ses
dimensions qui sont remis sur la table
quotidiennement donc oui je suis
consciente que c'est acquis il faut que
je continue à militer pour pouvoir les
maintenir mais il faut aussi que je
forme mes mes élèves filles comme
garçons à ces thématiques qui remettent
en cause tout le fonctionnement d'une
société pas simplement une partie de la
population
rita bonheur le féminisme comme vous le
disiez tout à l'heure des formes
diverses selon les époques selon les
pays selon les zones
est ce que l'on peut dire qu'à l'échelle
de la planète évidemment l'exercice un
peu compliqué est ce que il y avait
véritablement est ce qu'on nous pouvons
dire un bon mais ouf nous avons gagné
des combats droit à l'avortement le
droit de vote le droit des femmes de se
présenter aux élections de représenter
leur pays leur commune
que sais-je encore le droit à
l'autonomie économique même dans le
système français il n'ya pas très
longtemps il ya plus de 60 ans que les
femmes ont le droit d'avoir un compte
bancaire de faire des chèques d'avoir
une profession sans autorisation de leur
mari
c'est très récent nos grands mères ont
connu cette époque d'interdiction est ce
qu'un finalement à l'échelle de la
planète
on peut dire que nous avons franchi un
certain nombre d'étapes de 4 mais que
bon même si il y à des remises en cause
même si c'est difficile ici ou là
finalement on pourra plus vraiment
revenir en orient cette question je
pense qu'on est dans une marche
inexorable vers faire mieux un mieux
être pour les femmes dans la planète
mais mais avec comme on l'a dit un dd
chaos c'est à dire qu'il peut y avoir
des grosses avancées des reculs des
stagnations et c'est là qu'on voit que
tout ce mouvement
il ne peut pas être dissociée de tout le
reste c'est à dire du contexte politique
du contexte économique contexte social
des pays dans lesquels dans lesquelles
cela se situe et donc oui quand on est
en plein en pleine crise est bien qui
sont les premières dont on va remettre
en question le travail parce qu'elles
ont des travaux d elles ont un travail
précaire où elles ont pas de travail du
tout elles ont un travail informel enfin
je fais une toute petite parenthèse pour
dire qu'on l'a très bien vu dans cette
période de confinement dans différents
pays qu beaucoup de femmes avaient un
travail informel et que donc quand on
est enfermé chez soi mais on ne peut pas
de jaux b tout simplement
et comme on ne travaille pas de façon
déclaré on n'a pas droit à des
indemnités journalières
donc on est sans le sou et c'est là
qu'on voit toutes les facettes
on va dire de la situation des femmes et
donc est ce qu on a passé des caps oui
mais ces caps sont encore très fragile
est vraiment très inégaux selon les pays
bon quand on est encore jeune je ne veux
pas mettre à l'index l'inde tout le
temps mais quand on est encore dans des
pays où
eh bien on sait que le taux de foeticide
c'est ça est très important parce que eh
bien ça porte malheur d'avoir un bébé
fille et qu'on a déséquilibre de
plusieurs millions de personnes entre
femmes et hommes et que cela pose des
problèmes énormes dans la société
et ben voilà il faut se poser des
questions aussi des conséquences à long
terme de c2c de ses actes et de cette
façon de considérer les femmes dans la
société
en revenant à la haute et howie aux
thèses féministes
audrey célestine ou tout à l'heure vous
aviez pendant c'est un mot qui a
tendance à faire florès même s'il n'est
pas encore bien bien entré dans le
langage courant l'intersexualité ça nous
expliquer de quoi il s'agit mais j'ai
cru comprendre que en fait maintenant il
faut considérer les choses n'ont pas de
manière globale mais d'aller au plus fin
de la réalité sociologique et notamment
quand les féministes militantes ou les
les spécialistes de sciences sociales
qui étudie l'évolution du mouvement
féministe et la condition des femmes
eh bien nous sommes obligés de revenir à
aux conditions sociales des plus fine
possible selon les couches sociales et
les générations et les pays c'est bien
samedi 8 août
oui tout à fait en fait il s'agit
vraiment de de devoir a fait le terminer
il est relativement récent il a une
trentaine d'années il vient dé des
études juridiques mais en fait il est
vraiment fort j'ai par des militants et
des militantes en fait qui notamment les
féministes noirs aux états unis mais en
forme retrouvée de transats à sa
finalité au 19e siècle qui me se sentent
représentés ni dans le mouvement
antiraciste qui qui en fait mais surtout
en avant les hommes noirs il dit dans le
mouvement féministe qui concerne surtout
les enjeux rencontrés par les femmes
langer qui pose la question de mais
finalement calé nous notre place en fait
dans les noirs il ya des femmes et dans
des familles à ianu effectivement et du
coup l'intersexualité cette idée c'est
de prendre en compte la manière dont
diverses
divers types de pressions vont s'exercer
sur un individu et renforcer sa
domination et c'est vrai que c'est une
thématique qui a été précisément
théorisée par kimberly crenshaw aux
états unis dans des études juridiques
sur les discriminations qui s'applique
notamment aux femmes noires
dans ce contexte la c1 tam qui est très
mal compris dans le contexte français et
qui fait particulièrement peur on a
l'impression sa essentialise que ça dure
si les identités alors situé au
contraire mais qui permet effectivement
de saisir de manière un peu plus précise
un peu plus fine
quel type de de pression de domination
vont s'exercer de discrimination on
s'est exercée notamment sur des femmes
noires dans un contexte où elles sont
minoritaires face à la première
jean mas parti
à recoudre et célestine sociologue à
l'université de lille fabien de janas
professeur d'histoire géographie au
lycée de bellevue et ita bonnaire
présidente de l'union des femmes de
martinique beau voyage des quelque chose
par rapport à ce que andré celestini
vient de dieu sait où l'intersexualité
les manières de considérer les manières
différentiel la condition des femmes
selon couches sociales origines
ethniques sont géographique
non je voudrais dire que nous partageons
parfaitement cette analyse parce que
pour nous il est important effectivement
l'union des femmes de martinique depuis
sa création s'est positionné comme
partie prenante du mouvement social de
martinique ancré dans le mouvement
social
mais je veux dire que cette analyse que
je pense nous partageons autour de cette
table n'est pas celle de tout le monde
il faut rappeler que le courant
féministe et plurielle que le courant
féministe est très diversifiée géant
vidéo comme toutes les philosophies
peut-on dire est que vous avez des
femmes qui ne remettent absolument pas
en question la société telle qu'elle est
et dont l'ambition et jean vidéo de
faire autant que les hommes
donc bon jeu je répète que ce n'est pas
du tout l'analyse de l'ufm mais il faut
se rappeler que il y a aussi cessé ces
féministes là et que même si on peut
faire des bouts de chemin avec elle sur
certaines choses très concrètes
et bien il y a un vrai
clivage en fait dans cette analyse de la
société et donc plus particulièrement
justement pour ben tous des descendants
afrodescendants etc
cette analyse on ne peut pas faire
l'économie de cette analyse puisque ça
se pose avec encore plus d'acuité pour
nous d'après notre histoire
oui fabien de chanas vous avez travaillé
sur les femmes et en politique dans la
caraïbe en tout cas tu as quelques pays
de la caraïbe parce que rim c'est grand
c'est vaste est ce qui vous a frappé
d'après ce que j'ai compris c'est que la
condition des femmes étant inégale
évidemment comme on dit tout à l'heure
mais en fait dès qu'il s'agit de
politique on a à peu près les mêmes